so to a degree that is now even
surprising me and i've been following
this for a while
kovid is now
the republican virus in the united
states now liberals are still dying and
we're going to look at the data in a
moment but that's not exactly the point
here
the vaccine
uh
take up uptake
and mass guidelines have become so
partisan and so skewed politically
that the cumulative death rate
particularly since the vaccines have
been widely available i guess roughly
may of 2021
is now a three times higher death rate
in counties that voted 70 percent for
donald trump compared to counties that
voted only 30 percent to donald trump
this is
it's it's stunning
from a sort of
disconnected analytical perspective
and it's a tragic data set when we think
about the unnecessary life that's been
lost
and even if they don't care about people
dying
this should be a wake-up call for
republicans if they care about future
elections listen to this from npr
since may of 2021
people living in counties that voted
heavily for donald trump during last
election have been nearly three times as
likely to die from covid
than those who live in areas that went
for now president joe biden we have some
of this data visualized people living in
counties that went 60 percent or higher
for trump
had a 2.7 times higher death rate
than those that went for biden
counties with an even higher share of
the vote for trump saw even higher covet
19 mortality rates for example in
october
the reddest tenth of the country
saw death rates six times higher than
the bluest 10th of the country it is
absurd to a degree
that is even surprising me at this point
in time now over the last few weeks
the gap has shrunk a little bit but in
those super red versus super blue
counties it's still a five and a half
times higher death rate
uh
absolutely incredible now let's go
through some of the talking points that
you will hear
from the right
mostly the talking point on these
numbers is you've got to control for age
republicans are on average older
republican counties are on average older
and the age difference explains the
difference in death rates and the the
response is
no it does not
even when controlling for age this is
the trend dramatically higher death rate
in
trump counties rather than biden
counties
now
on the other flip side of this going
back to what we talked about with
marjorie taylor green earlier
the higher the trump vote share
the lower the vaccination rate this is
not like cancer even though margaery
taylor green said we don't shut down for
cancer this is not like cancer in that
with cancer we don't know the causes of
many types of cancer cancers with many
we do with many we don't many different
types here we know
and the trend is clear more vaccination
lower death and we also see more trump
vote
a lower vaccination rate these are the
trump vaccines as they like to say trump
came up with them trump wants you to
believe he synthesized to sequence the
virus himself and his voters still don't
want them now obviously we don't know
the politics of the individuals who die
a biden voter in a red county can still
die and they do
a trump voter in a blue county can still
die and they do
but the association here is extreme and
it even goes beyond this
it is likely on the basis of the lower
vaccination rate among republicans now
the lowest vaccinated demographic group
in the united states that even the
deaths
in the blue counties probably skew
towards republicans relative to their
share of the population a lot of right
wingers call me on my voicemail and they
say david
why are you they don't say david sir no
they just say david or even worse names
um why aren't you
talking about how black people won't get
vaccinated and every time i check the
numbers to see has something changed
and it hasn't black folks
do have a lower vaccination rate than
some other groups but it is still
significantly higher than the
vaccination rate among republicans
republicans are now the largest
unvaccinated group
there is no
single
demographic factor when you look at
gender
uh race
educational level across all of these
being a republican right now
is the signal
that you are most likely to be
unvaccinated right now now at some point
the public health tragedy that has been
this pandemic
could become a political tragedy for
republicans if they keep going with the
current approach
i'm not giving them advice
my concern is i care about people's
lives regardless of their politics
and as we've said before your decision
not to get vaccinated doesn't only put
you at risk but we we're beyond that
if republicans care about election
strategy
you would think that they'd be saying
it's not good for us to
disproportionately lose
more of our voters than they are losing
of theirs
i don't know what it'll take to get them
to change their tune
if you're having trouble thinking of
what to give someone as a holiday gift
check out our sponsor shaker and spoon
the monthly cocktail subscription box
delivering the ingredients and recipes
for craft cocktails right to your door
they send you everything you need to
make the cocktails except for the
alcohol you provide that it comes with a
really nice recipe card easy to follow
my most recent shaker and spoon cocktail
creation was called the capri crush it's
a campari gin drink with spiced orange
grapefruit cordial and dash fire orange
bitters delicious my turned out great i
know nothing about mixing drinks neither
do most of my friends but with my shaker
and spoon cocktails i ended up looking
like i knew something about it which is
good it's very good for my cred
you don't have to go to a crowded bar to
enjoy an excellent cocktail shaker and
spoon lets you do it all at home great
for date nights makes a perfect gift and
you'll get 20 off when you use the promo
code pacman at checkout go to
shakerandspoon.com
pacman and the link is down below